bonjour bonjour à tous alors oui comme
l'a dit un fait nous nous sentons place
écrit bord et j'espère d'entendre ça
mais notre projet et s'est construit à 5
donc nous avons pu être présent à 3
aujourd'hui pourrait restons une
pratique mais les deux personnes qui
travaillent avec nous son sens avec nous
et ont réalisé autant que nous ce projet
donc voilà on les remercie aussi même
cet impôt pu être là ce soir
donc aujourd'hui on va parler du
plastique d'un projet un problème pardon
mondiale récurrents qu'on entend souvent
dans les médias soit même en fait quand
on voit un peu les ce qui se passe dans
le recyclage et du coup il faut savoir
en fait je vous donner quelques chiffres
aujourd'hui dans le monde c 311
milliards de tonnes de plastique
produite par mme donc c'est un gros
chien tout ça représente tout plastique
donc que ce soit le président d'un
industriel que le plastique quotidien
qu'on utilise et pourparlers avec un
exemple un peu plus concret on va parler
de sacs plastiques
celui qu'on l'utilisé quand on allait
faire une course et c est encore
aujourd'hui alors même que ça a été
interdite
en europe hors france c'est encore mille
milliards de sacs plastiques produits
par an il faut savoir que ce sac
plastique qui est pourtant assez léger
et qui peut se dégrader facilement avec
la main et ben pourtant dans la nature
quand il est jeté il dure de 400 à 1000
années avant d'être des ancres
entièrement dégradé et inoffensives pour
l'environnement
donc c'est un réel problème et nous nous
avons souhaité nous concentrer sur une
zone particulière qui est touchée par la
pollution plastique donc à ce constat on
peut aussi rajouter que chaque année
dans le monde environ 8 millions de
tonnes de déchets sont déversés dans nos
océans
là alors je vous parle on peut constater
pas moins de 2,9 milliards de tonnes de
déchets dans nos eaux
partant de ce constat depuis 1997
on emploie même le terme de 7e continent
pour désigner l'immense masse de
plastique découverte dans le pacifique
le long de long de l'amérique d'une
taille à peu près équivalente à six fois
celle de la france pour vous rajouter
encore un peu plus de données d'après
une étude réalisée par le pm eux c'est
environ 40000 micro plastiques qui sont
présents tout les milles nautiques c'est
à dire environ 30000 microplastiques par
kilomètre carré dans notre séant alors
oui c'est beaucoup de chiffres en très
peu de temps mais ça ramène à des prêts
à des problèmes bien concret car on
estime qu'il existe environ des micro
plastiques sur toutes les plages du
monde
donc ce qui est vrai pour des plages
d'amérique latine comme le brésil par
exemple se vérifie aussi en bretagne
comme sur une plage comme moulin blanc
le trait cia etc
si par exemple vous pensiez allait
passer vos vacances tranquillement en
méditerranée cet été laissez-moi vous
annoncer que vous ne serez pas les seuls
car d'après une étude scientifique menée
en 2010 il existe pas moins de 250
milliards de micro plastique qui
flottent déjà on peut donc dire sans
beaucoup s'avancer que l'océan est
devenue la plus grande poubelle au monde
le challenge est vraiment d'endiguer la
prolifération de ces déchets tant qu'ils
sont encore sur la terre ferme
alors ces chiffres sont très
intéressants mais en fait nous dans
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
finalement à notre échelle qu'est ce
qu'on peut qu'est ce qu'on peut
amenez alors on n'est ni chercheurs ni
professionnelle dans ce domaine on est
étudiant et on s'est quand même lancé le
défi de faire quelque chose alors c'est
de cette idée que quénéa plastique liban
notre association dont l'objet est de
promouvoir des initiatives qui visent à
recycler le plastique d'une façon
originale et à revaloriser les déchets
plastiques
alors vous savez peut-être que environ
25 % des déchets que vous jetez déchets
plastiques que vous jeter à la poubelle
seulement 25% sont effectivement
recyclés les 75% restants sont seulement
brûlés alors l'idée c'est d'avoir le
plastique d'une façon différente
on l'a fait beaucoup de recherches et on
a réussi à trouver quelque part dans le
monde en l'occurrence en argentine des
personnes qui voient le plastique d'une
façon différente dont par exemple notre
entre notre partenaire principal la
casse à dallas bouteille à ce qui veut
dire maison en bouteille et eux ils
construisent en fait tout simplement des
maisons à base de comme matière première
des bouteilles plastiques
alors l'idée l'entreprise est née vers
les années la fin la fin des années 90
les débuts des années 2000
et c'était à cause de la forte crise
économique qui a touché l'argentine à ce
moment là le créateur de cette
entreprise monsieur alfredo alberto
santa cruz s'est retrouvé sans emploi du
jour au lendemain et a dû trouver un
moyen de subvenir aux besoins de sa
famille il est comme il a comme beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres il est allé dans la
rue et il a ramassé des déchets qu'il a
trié puis revendus aux grandes firmes et
c'est quelque chose qui se passe même
aujourd'hui même en argentine
c'est quelque chose de commun alors
l'idée principale de la construction des
maisons en plastique est venue lorsque
sa petite fille lui a demandé de lui
acheter une maison de poupée évidemment
bas il était sans emploi ils n'avaient
pas forcément les moyens de la lui
offrir alors il s'est dit pourquoi je
vais pas la construire il ay laprise la
matière première qu'il avait sous la
main c'est à dire des déchets et il l'a
construit une maison à partir de
bouteilles plastiques une fois le
résultat vu devant ses yeux il s'est dit
pas pourquoi je ferais pas c'est
pourquoi je l'on construirait pas ses
maisons à l'échelle humaine
alors évidemment ça a pris du temps des
années et cette entreprise a été créée
l'idea le concept a été affinée et en
2005 l'entreprise a été reconnue
d'intérêt municipale et nationale en
argentine et en effet du coup à partir
de 2005 cette entreprise s'est vraiment
développée et le concept s'est améliorée
grâce à des bénévoles et des
professionnels qui sont venus construire
avec lui en fait avec monsieur santa
cruz ces maisons et donc améliorer le
procédé donc là vous pouvez voir une
maison enfin deux maisons et donc en
fait pour vous donner un peu une idée
sur un mètre carré il y à peu près 60
bouteilles
ces bouteilles sont agencés les unes
dans les autres donc le procédé n'est
pas secret mais que quand même comme
garder
par monsieur santa cruz c'est lui qui a
inventé ce procédé est donc 60
bouteilles ça correspond à 3 $ 50 à peu
près et donc du coup une maison entière
ont peu à peu près à aller à 1300 1300
euros 1300 de la fin coup 1400 dollars
et du coup c'est vraiment une fin c'est
abordable c'est abordable pour les
personnes les populations qui habitent
là-bas et
nous du coup on a souhaité pouvoir aider
à ce niveau là et le
il faut savoir aussi que du coup
monsieur santa cruz a pu grâce à ce
procédé a connu il a construit avec les
professionnels qui l'ont aidé plus de 70
maisons
à ce jour ces maisons tienne tiennent
encore debout
elles sont là depuis donc sur certaines
les premières depuis 20 ans et donc le
certainement fin par exemple la toiture
pour céder parce qu'on l'a on voit que
des bouteilles plastiques mais aussi des
fois du carton tetrapak ce qu'on utilise
pour les boules et les briques de lait
ou tout ça et du coup donc vraiment
toutes les fournitures même le
fourniture de la maison sont construites
en plastique et donc du coup
actuellement monsieur santa cruz est
invité dans des séminaires pour
expliquer pour parler de ce qu'il a
réussi à réaliser de son entreprise et
viendra peut-être même aussi en france
dc pour l'année prochaine lorsqu'elle
est important de préciser aussi c'est
que la somme de 1300 euros correspond à
la valeur des déchets à réunir pour une
construction mais ça ne prend pas en
compte le prix du transport qui varient
d'un pays à un autre et c'est pourquoi
monsieur santa cruz fait souvent appel
aux dons car toutes les familles qui
souhaitent aider ne peuvent pas se
permettre de rater soit de rassembler
des déchets soit la somme nécessaire au
rachat de ces déchets donc suite à la
découverte de cette entreprise nous
avons signé un contrat de partenariat en
date du 21 février dernier et deux
objectifs en ont dégagé premièrement
nous souhaitons financer par nous mêmes
la construction d'une d'une maison
écologique de la casa das boot eyath
pour prouver que même depuis la bretagne
nous pouvons agir pour changer les
choses
à l'autre bout du monde dans une optique
de cercle vertueux de réutilisation des
déchets deuxièmement notre association
compte aller directement sur place en
amérique latine pour tourner un
reportage photos et vidéos que nous
pourrons exposé ensuite en bretagne à
notre tour nous souhaitons surtout nous
focaliser sur les impacts de la
pollution sur les littoraux pouvons
faire un peu d'être éco ou dangers
pouvant menacer la bretagne mais
également sur la réelle culture du
recyclage et commence à se développer en
argentine grâce à nos partenariats avec
la cassadotte beauté liasse nous avons
vraiment une place de choix puisque nous
pourrons montrer l'intérieur comment se
monte un projet un projet humanitaire
mais nous ne sommes pas arrêté là
puisque nous voulons surtout mettre en
avant l'expérience et le contact humain
et c'est pour ça que nous sommes aussi
partis à la rencontre des acteurs locaux
aux rencontres la pollution plastique
dans un premier temps nous avons eu la
chance de rencontrer l'association ouest
factory qui a pour projet de vraiment
démocratiser le recyclage du du déchet
plastique
ils sont en train de mettre en place des
de concevoir et de mettre en place des
bourgs ailleurs qui permettrait à toute
personne entrant de leurs locaux avec
nos propres déchets plastiques de les
transformer en objets de toutes sortes
ça peut être des outils des objets de
déco et bien plus encore donc si demain
il vous manque un bol à la maison mais
vous avez quelques bouteilles plastiques
dans un camp aubryste factory pourra
peut-être vous prouver
la solution dans un deuxième temps nous
avons rencontré la start up
si les fab qui s'inscrit vraiment dans
dans des questions presse trois actuels
puisque pour une ville portuaire comme
la nôtre c'est vrai que les filets de
pêche ce n'est pas ce qui manque
le problème cependant c'est leur
recyclage de manière de manière
intelligente et c'est le challenge que
s'est lancé chez les femmes depuis la
récolte des filets de pêche auprès des
pêcheurs jusqu'à leur réhabilitation
chez les faibles s'inscrit dans une
démarche de design de transition en
proposant des objets fabriqués avec ces
matières premières comme par exemple des
dessous de table dessous de verre pardon
des chaussures et bientôt peut-être du
mobilier encore au stade de
conceptualisations mais on ne s'est pas
arrêté là on n'a pas seulement à être
été à la rencontre des associations
étaient start-up brestoise on a essayé
on a aussi été à la rencontre d'artistes
brestois donc c'est au niveau des du
plateau des capucins derrière la
médiathèque
il ya une petite rue et là bas on peut
pas on peut pas louper vraiment la
petite étincelle de joie que ce que ce
petit jardin amène dans le quartier on a
été à la rencontre du monsieur qui a qui
vit dans cette maison qui est il apte à
d'ailleurs été très surpris de nous voir
et on lui a demandé comment quel est le
comment il utilise en fait comment ils
décorent son jardin alors il nous a dit
qu'ils utilisaient des tuyaux de
chantier des bouteilles en plastique il
est d'ailleurs connue pour son arbre à
badoit il crée des phares avec son avec
des tuyaux de chantier il utilise des
crocs des dépôts de fleurs donc vraiment
c'est nous a appris il nous a fait voir
la réutilisation du plastique et la
revalorisation du plastique vraiment à
sa juste valeur
alors évidemment en attendant que notre
projet se fasse on n'est pas né pas
rester comme ça sur le côté en attendant
que l'argent tombe du ciel
on a été on a postulé à des appels à
projets on
on n'a pas participé à celui du crédit
agricole de la banque populaire de
l'ouest à celui de nescafé project
starter et aussi à celui de léa nature
alors peut-être que vous vous demandez
et nous dans tout ça est d'accord et
ensuite vous pouvez aussi nous aider on
va lancer dans les jours à venir notre
campagne de crowdfunding et vous pourrez
suivre tout ce qui se passe là dessus
sur les réseaux sociaux on est présent
sur facebook twitter et youtube et on va
poster souvent des updates pour vous
expliquer où on est notre terre à quel
stade en est notre projet et et vous
pourrez évidemment participer à cette
campagne de crowdfunding fait faire
votre parti ont peut-être donnant un
petit don voilà faire un petit don merci
et du coup on a ça s'arrête pas là bien
sûr on vous a dit tout à l'heure qu'on
avait deux objectifs donc c'était la
construction de la maison qui donc avec
bientôt avec les appels à projets et
tout çà et là
la campagne de crowdfunding et on a
aussi donc ce reportage
on va partir en argentine réalisé donc
un reportage vidéo photo et pouvoir
revenir ici faire une exposition
mais ce n'est pas tout on souhaite aussi
grâce à en fait nos contacts aux
personnes qu'on a pu rencontrer ici
localement et même plus loin ailleurs
parce qu'en fait c'est des initiatives y
en a partout dans le monde c'est ça qui
est génial c'est vraiment ça nous donne
un peu d'espoir quand même sur la
l'avenir qui peut paraître un peu noir
parfois du coup nous ont souhaité quand
même à notre échelle le pouvoir aider
ces personnes qui se lancent et donc de
créer une plateforme qui répertoriait
répertorie freinerait répertoire de
toutes les personnes qui donc se sont
lancés sur ces domaines là et donc de
pouvoir céder entre l est
avoir des informations s'échangent et
les informations et nous mêmes
ensuite plus tard aussi si le futur ce
est bon pour nous de pouvoir les aider
donc vraiment de pouvoir grâce à des
soupes nous nous aurons récupéré de
pouvoir soutenir ces initiatives qu'elle
aille plus loin et qu'elles puissent
ensuite pouvoir se
être dans la société en fait être
impliqué dans la société et être utilisé
ce n'est pas tout d'ailleurs plus
localement ce n'est pas tout dans un
futur plus proche
on attend avec impatience la rentrée
prochaine pour vraiment s'impliquer dans
des projets de sensibilisation dans des
écoles primaires des communes
avoisinantes
donc je pense surtout s'orienter vers
des ateliers pratiques qui pourront
aller même jusqu'à la réalisation de
petites maisons en plastique comme vous
voyez ici à l'image de ce que de ce que
fait notre partenaire en argentine de
plus on and on a commencé des prises de
contact avec l'ambassade française en
argentine pour étudier la faisabilité
d'un jumelage entre la ville de brest et
puerto iguaçu alors pour finir on
aimerait d'abord remercié les
organisateurs de cet événement mr
remercier monsieur champions qui nous a
invités ce soir on voudrais aussi
remercier notre partenaire local
finistère 2.9 qui nous a accompagnés
tout au long de notre projet et qui nous
a aidé à créer un réseau et dans la
communication à travers les réseaux
sociaux
ça paraît aussi important évidemment de
précis de remercier la casse à dallas
beauté liasse notre partenaire en
argentine qui va nous aider à mener ce
projet à son terme
et merci à vous d'être présent ce soir
merci
[Applaudissements]